[Musique]
l'immobilier d'entreprise c'est 4
millions us 6 mètres carrés de
d'immobilier d'entreprise tous confondus
[Musique]
nous notre rôle c'est d'accompagner les
porteurs de projets à trouver des soies
des terrains disponibles soit des
bâtiments pour pour pouvoir implanter
leurs activités
[Musique]
à l'heure actuelle nous avons environ
entre 250000 et 300 mille mètres carrés
en cours de développement
quand on dit en cours de développement
ce sont des projets sur lesquels on
travaille avec les opérateurs en 2019 on
a fait une année vraiment très
intéressant pas aussi bonne que celle de
2018 mais très intéressante avec avec
des grands comptes qui ont qui ont bougé
[Musique]
les entreprises réfléchissent beaucoup à
la suite qu'ovide à la suite télétravail
le télétravail c'est le continue de se
développer
les entreprises ont libéré des mètres
carrés va falloir les animer il va
falloir créer de nouvelles surfaces
créer de nouveaux usages faire des
espaces de coworking faire des espaces
d'animation pour que les salariés
puissent se rencontrer pour que les
équipes projets puissent se rencontrer
également
[Musique]